ashley what's going on how can i help
basically um i have a 12 year old son
that has adhd and asperger's syndrome
and he's right now he has a fixation
on horror videos subjects
and pornography and his
counselor that we've been seeing for
we've
for a couple of months he doesn't seem
to
feel like it's a big deal but what we
really do
he's 12 he's he's 12.
oh my gosh well stop seeing that
counselor today
geez louise what a [ __ ] why would he
say that's not a big deal
i i don't know he's he's addressed it
with them but he
always just kind of well you know i
think you're
you know you're above that you you know
that shouldn't be something you
you know you would be interested in but
he's 12.
every 12 year old on the planet is
interested in naked people
that's why they have got parents that
get between them and viewing naked
people why because they're children
god almighty any counselor that says ah
it's i mean they shouldn't but it's cool
dude should not be a therapist
especially a child therapist
unbelievable man just just the
scientific research
about how these poor kids are blowing
the herdonic sensors out of their back
of their heads
with i'm getting fired up and this is
not at you ashley you are beautiful and
lovely and wonderful and i'm glad that
you called
i am just can't believe my own ears that
therapists would do this
if a 12 year old is coming to see me
this is a red alert moment
because the research on these kids who
start looking at pornography at young
ages
are unable to have erections at 23 24.
they are unable to hold relationships
they are melting
their sexual partners because of their
uh
misguided understanding of what sex is
they're getting sex education from
pornography
and this is a stop the presses moment
for me
this is pull all the internet on my
house if i have to turn every screen off
in my house if i have to
i'm not going to put that garbage in my
kids head i'm not going to let them have
access to it in any way shape form or
fashion
ever i don't care if they have aspergers
or add or anything like that right
um and this and the same is going to go
with um
horror movies quite frankly when it
comes to what kind of horror are you
talking about
um i mean it's anywhere from
like friday to 13th all the way through
he's got fixations on serial killers and
actually actually where is he getting
this stuff
he's he's hearing about it he hears
about it from his friends
and the worst part is now that
he's back in school they all have
chromebooks
and he gets on and we'll we'll look at
his history and
he'll do maybe five or ten minutes of
class work and then he's on youtube and
he's just
searching and just no all right listen
you are all in the school um
principal's office tomorrow at 8am you
take the day off of work if you got to
because those are supposed to have
filters on them he's a child
they're supposed to have filters on them
they're supposed to not be able to just
surf the web they're supposed to
have a lot of breaks in those
chromebooks right and i was intentional
about asking those questions with my kid
you get in there that morning and enough
12 year olds should be watching radar
movies
in school they shouldn't be watching
them at all for god's sakes man
yeah and again this is has nothing to do
with diagnostics
kids are into things that get their
heart rate racing
right that's their kids and this is not
about his diagnostics this is about the
fact that he's 12.
right he's 12-year-old boy wants to
check out naked people he's a 12 year
old boy that wants to check out
cool exciting ooh and ah violent crazy
things
right and that's a parent's job that's a
school's job that's a counselor job it's
a teacher's job to protect these kids
actually so i would be all
up in there and if not i'm going to
throw that computer in there and then
we're going to do this thing the old
school way because i'm not going to have
my kid
in that poison and that trash no chance
no way no how
we can't help the conversations that our
kids are having
with their classmates i actually don't
those don't bother me they give me a
great avenue
into my son's heart and my daughter's
heart and so i like hearing about words
that they've learned and conversations
and
some of them are hard and uncomfortable
but that gives me a great avenue to have
conversations with my kid right
so and they're going to have that for
the rest of their life they're going to
hear stuff at college they're going to
hear stuff at the workplace they're
going to hear stuff at some local bar
having a beer with their buddies
they're going to hear those things so
that doesn't bother me because those are
other 12 year olds
what bothers me is there's no adults
stepping up in
this kid's life man that are saying not
on my watch
you know what i mean yeah yeah i do
you're you're at a burn the ships moment
ashley for the heart and mind of your
son
okay okay right and i i hate
i just wait i want to make sure it
wasn't just
us i didn't feel like we were
overreacting but
when we when you know the professional
tells us that
we are nonsense you tell that [ __ ] to
call me
on my own show i'd love to talk to him
i would love to right or take this
youtube clip and uh whenever it comes
out
and then email it to him and say we want
i want to discuss this at the next
session
except hopefully by the time this comes
out you're not having any more sessions
geez louise
and by the way is this the same guy that
diagnosed your child as
add slash asperger's no
that was that was a psychiatrist several
years ago
okay we we switched to this guy
because because we kept having that
reoccurring problem with him
searching for things and and they
and the group suggested that we meet
with him because he may be
more open to talking to someone to
talking to a male instead of a female
sure counselor that's and that's fair
kids kids
will talk to different people with
different levels of comfort that's
awesome
but when you're working with a child you
have to remember that
when your kid is seeing a child
counselor psychologist
what you the parent are the actual
client there
you get to talk through what the
treatment's gonna look like
not that you get to decide what the
outcome is gonna be but you get to come
into those and say my kid
is already developing a pathology an
addiction towards
pornography we've got to stop this and i
need some help
and if a therapist is going to say well
i don't really do that i do guided
directive therapy with 12 year olds and
say
you're an idiot and then go find
somebody else that's going to help you
solve this
immediate crisis of a problem with your
12 year old
okay now here's the other thing if your
child truly
is on the um autism spectrum
right and again i want you to go have
somebody else check this
anytime somebody just throws asperger's
an add that's actually the language
isn't even what they use anymore
they've got different language for that
diagnostic and so i'd recommend getting
that tested
and see but man if you start developing
some of these long-term patterns from
these long-term
loops with somebody on the autism
spectrum disorder
it is unfathomable how hard it will be
to unwind some of that
a kid with adhd tendencies who's coming
from a chaotic
situation who maybe doesn't fit in a
traditional classroom so we're just
going to label him
that's a whole other conversation but
that kid is going to suffer from this
addictive this looping this routine
driven this chaos pushing
man he's going to be searching search
and searching so we've got to get extra
intentional
now about having alternative behaviors
alternative things
and for a 12 year old that means
complete restriction
not learning to live with not hey listen
ashley your mom
gut was right your mom heart was right
okay okay listen yeah follow your gut
follow your heart you know that boy
better than anybody okay
all right uh thank you all right so
listen
you didn't screw anything up you
listened to the professionals you did
what they told you to
and i'm super glad that you called um
it's time to get
in it's time to it's time to turn into
advocate mama
it's time to go be war mama now and
again you're in that school office 8
o'clock tomorrow morning show the
history
and say this is not going to happen and
it's not up to the 12 year old to not go
to these sites because they're 12.
right good grief and drive me crazy